we would like to read a letter from the
44th President of the United States
Barack Obama sent in regarding the life
and celebration of Nipsey Hussle written
today this morning at April 11 2019 the
friends and family of Nipsey Hussle I've
never met nipsey but I've heard his
music through my daughters and after his
passing I had the chance to learn more
about his transformation and his
community work while most folks look at
the Crenshaw neighborhood where he grew
up and only see gangs bullets and
despair
Nipsey saw potential he saw hope he saw
a community that even through its flaws
taught him to always keep going his
choice to invest in that community his
choice to invest in that community
rather than to ignore it to build a
Skills Training Center a co-working
space in Crenshaw to lift up the
eritrean American community he set an
example for young people to follow and
there's a legacy worth of celebration I
hope his memory inspires more good work
in Crenshaw and communities like it
Michelle and I send our sympathies to
Lauren
Imani cross and his whole family and to
all those who love NIF see sincerely
Barack Obama
[Applause]